こんにちははじめ社長ですあの
僕が最近の趣味なんですけど深夜にスーパーとかの丘整理ばに行くことなんですよ
おかしいありばとかに行くとよくあるあのちょっとクオリティの高いお菓子付き望み
食べちゃうじゃないですか
それの最強バージョンを見つけましたこちらアニマギアと呼ばれるものでございますで
説明がありますアニマギ後はあらゆる体物の動きが記憶
され竜を可動範囲をフレームボーンフレーム7合金から精製された投稿
mick karn 太陽光エネルギーに変形するコンバートフィルム
ブラックスてからの3つのギアを組み合わせて楽しむ新せないバディをボビー
ボビーじゃんっ切った木を組んで楽しむシーン世代 barbie ホビーのことで
あるらしいです
3つのパッドスピードてるっぽいですね汚し
であるんですけどもこれを組み合わせて自由に作ることができるんですよ
多分これ開けると自分でまず作るんですよ組み立てるそして j に動くぽいです彼等
フレームそしてこのパート中に組み合わせることができるキャスターぬ
男心をくすぐらせる3つの要素が組み込まれている最強の食玩となっております
折り合えず一回作って3日
[音楽]
はいとりあえず後それやるんでちょっと見ていきましょうかまずこちらな漫画例を
そろえ+ by
色がめっちゃ好きですねこれナンバー2積みナーガスベビーですねこれだと蛇
仲悪そうな南してますねす前そちらバースゲーター
データどぅアリゲーターはニっぽいですいやマンこちら
シュバルツちょっとな見た目がめっちゃかけごはん by スポーツ白い以下じゃね
4どこにカーサこれ合体するっぽいすれば1回も作ったことないんでちょっとどれだけ
カスタマイズできるか分からないんですけども
とりあえず一回全部作ってみます
わー細すげー f 組み立て力やばいんだけどこれめっちゃ強いんだろうなこれ多分
完成品館いただきます
これでもたぶんこういうの作るのとべ波家も早く行けると思うよ
ん
[音楽]
違う相手で結構進んだんですけどもとにしっかり作っていきたいんで
爪切りとかニッパーたら作って正確に作っていますそうやって重視で作っていきます
pa
んできた相手目で完成しました
がれよストライカーツヴァイでございます
はいこ様食玩か本当にそんなに混まないのないんでカードをすごくてじっとンパって
動くし
も手足チョコめちゃくちゃ行きますスタッツをた常しますか立たせてみます
[音楽]
ちょっと今急ぎで行ったんですけどもこうすればもうにそっと方向にも変形することが
できます凄いぞマジで不味いで5色がんですよ皆さん食玩
食玩でこんなくるデータ台の作るちょっとはえぇ
残りねっとなるんですとその結果作って並べてみると思いますはいはいというわけで
こちらが号3ランにバギーでございますかっこいいね個人的にはこれが一番好きなん
ですけどもほかねーぞみてくださいこれ
先ほど見せた彼はストライカーツヴァイこの蛇みたいながゼミナールが側にみたいな
やつがバースゲーター
そしてこれにたいこれ合体するんですよ sugar
まずもっとば is for とやったらですもう今この人たちだけでも変形度はする
んですけども合体とかカスタマイズできるでしょ
ちょっとこの2台が合体できるでちょっとやってみます説明書作り方入ったように滑っ
てみます
おります
別て part るよ大丈夫それか不安にあるけどパーツとるって書いてるんですけど
booty もております初数回転させます
も色々話しデーきっ
[音楽]
を押しました
います下全然違うこれどういう作りん
すごいすごいすごいすごいすごいすごいする
もうすごいすごいすごいすごい
[音楽]
えっすごいすごいすごいすごいいやすごい
金
すごい結構僕のオリジナリティーが入ったんですけども合体させるとこんな感じで2個
みたいなやつの返球することができます
いや数行音が後半も説明書との見ずに感覚で作ってしまいました
こういうめちゃくちゃ狂い咲け方
私今までひらめきましたアニマギはこれさんではたくさんあればあるほど
すげーものが作れるんじゃないでしょうか結構順に組み合わせられそうだったので
たくさんのこれやばいの作れるんじゃねって事で
ハイダーにムーア50個中3人
をするやると
出発準備したんでこんなに罰があれば僕は思いで最強の兄がギアを頑張って組はて
つけるぐらいの大量のパズルゲームと思って本来このたい量だけだけをつくって
最強のボーン数を住みたいと思います
ちょっと支えに多すぎるんで一人だと無理なんでちょっとみんなで驚愕しなどがまず
パートでも出しますでは
em
[音楽]
ん
9 i 努力でアニメマギや50体作りました
[拍手]
[音楽]
あの大
さすがにヤバかったです太田いけないだったらあの一人作ってちょうどいい感じだった
んですけど50体ます
ニッチ区畠田スタッフ全員でおらーてもうちょっとで作りました
俺何があればも組み合わせ月いうなんでちょっとやばいアニマギ愛の僕も作れるんじゃ
ないかと思ったんでちょっと頑張って合体させていきたいとおもいます
色とかが結構いけそうで例えばが両トライカードの墓所でめっちゃ
色がかっこいいでが年くらいからだけで自分にかかってるって事
ほんと工夫じゃないんだけどがんばります
[音楽]
できました
バッハ福井のべちゃべちゃっと実は撮影朝からして今深夜の12時までかかりました
あの本当にできることがあまりに多すぎてスッキリ頭使ったんですけども
5私123456789
10種類ほどアニマギヤー自分で考えてみたのでぜひご覧くださいませ
k
かっこいいやつからふざけた奴とかなんか邪魔のパート使ってる奴は色々あるんで是非
ご参考までにどうぞ
[音楽]
はいという人々に職人魂と思いましたアニマギやイカがあったでしょ
めっちゃ素敵で汗かくことハマっちゃったんですけども凄くないですかこれ
食玩ですよ改めて引佐おかしいねば言ってる食玩でございますこれ
このクオリティな奴はマジで見たことないして本当にねかスタメンとめちゃくちゃ
しっかりできてあの正直めちゃくちゃ気をいつ何時楽しかったですって何
言えない家なんですけれども実は第1弾が去年の8月に販売されていたらしいんです
けども
その時と比べてですねだからすぐパンツが外れにくくなってて使用かなりグレード
アップしてるんで相当もクオリティが高くなっているみたいでございますで本当に
すごかったというようなに間にはもう本当に不くるのは他の選手で使ったとそのカード
はいてもすごい
そして組み合わせでこんなにいるの
な作れるやんねえ香本といっ収穫であればこれもっとやばいの作れると思うんですよ
本当に自信はありますそしてアニマギあのすごいとかねこちらなど1個をねなんだ
散華90円です激安ですこの値段でこのクオリティやばいって言うけど本当に何か男の
心がくすぐられる素晴らしいショックガンでございました
あそあにはには24aug からおかしいればだ
販売されるのでぜひ皆さん遊んでみてください案にはギアの詳しい詳細はどうぞの概要
欄にありますぜひスターで確認してみてください
で根源 mvb はこちらのにたいですねもう漆黒のブラックと正義のクリムゾン
ネット白赤の組み合わせこの2体がもう一番カッコよかったです
[音楽]
ブーブーんっ
あった
[音楽]